you want to be a normal
teenager I got news for you you're not
normal Doris who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him you could say that about any
place my brother's dying he hasn't
talked in years I'm so sorry my wife
passed away my dad died when I was three
Christ it ain't a
competition I think I should start
sleeping at Sunco so your brother
doesn't get too lonely he's my child
when he's in pain I'm in pain I'm your
child too what about God sake give me a
break you can come to my house if you
need to place a party my mom won't be
there and you can do whatever you want
oh my God I I have to tell everybody um
but who who are
you everyone says this neighborhood is
scary but like when you're in it it's
like not that
scary thank
you it's really hard Tak care of sick
people sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
doors he could have died and you weren't
here once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taking care of
him you'll miss everything all the good
all the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how got it be fun
again Doris old lady's name it was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
depressing
[Music]
me